[Music]  Demi Lovato's ex is supporting her after  her apparent drug overdose Wilmer  Valderrama was spotted entering  cedars-sinai Medical Center in LA to pay  the sorry not sorry singer a visit just  one day after she was hospitalized he  rusted him aside a day after her rep  released a statement sharing this update  Demi is awake and with her family  everyone goes through ups and downs and  I'm getting to write about that I'm so  source close to Wilmer tells ET he is  shattered by Jimmy's overdose and while  he was aware of her relapse earlier this  year he did not anticipate this I've  been able to share my story with other  people and I've had fans that come up to  me and tell me you know because you got  sober I got sober  despite the couple calling it quits in  2016 they remain good friends a source  told ET quote he has and will always  believe in her he's watched her fall and  has seen her rise I think Demi isn't a  pad for you know for mega stardom  [Music]